when did you begin studying Netflix TV
shows a few years ago um definitely when
I was uh coming out developing my book
on TV um story Maps TV drama the
structure of the 1-hour television pilot
where I broke down the structure of one
hour pilots from a lot of different
networks and streamers and stuff and I
definitely wanted to have some Netflix
shows in there um and in that first book
I broke down house of cards which was
like the seminal big that was their
first big show that they produced and
distributed um so that was a big
Benchmark for them um and now I mean
they've had hundreds of shows since then
of course but uh but yeah it's
fascinating and and writers always ask
me about that and they're like Netflix
has a thousand shows how can I get mine
in there you know which is a normal
question you know um but it is extremely
competitive and the thing is everybody
wants to get on Netflix even the
established filmmakers and established
TV people and for a while I don't know
if they're still doing it Netflix was
overpaying the market for everybody they
were paying anyone more than other
companies were giving them it's actually
kind of in their in their company rules
is if you're an employee of Netflix and
you can prove that someone who does your
same job at another company gets more
money than you they will raise your
salary up to that level at least that's
the way they started Reed Hastings put
in that rule when they first started um
but content-wise I mean they're a huge
uh Studio they're a huge Factory they do
every genre imaginable so it's an
exciting place um their financials are
crazy everybody's kind of like we don't
know how
they uh fund so much stuff billions and
billions of dollars of content but
somehow they do it and so they're a big
dog
definitely what if you you learned about
the structure of Netflix TV
shows well they distinguish themselves
from definitely the major networks the
broadcast networks in that they target
audiences and topics more succinctly you
know they're focused more on a niche
that's kind of first off you know your
broadcast networks like ABC NBC CBS and
even a lot of your uh basic cable
channels they're going for a broad
audience I mean it's right in there in
the title they want basically everyone
um they want uh every generation of the
family to watch their show so they're
not that risky they're not that edgy
they're not cutting edge with style and
tone and film making but Netflix uh
decided they were going to be edgy and
be more adult and more mature and I mean
in some cases just more R-rated and they
came out with House of Cards and it was
more like a movie it looked cinematic
and it had nudity and bad language and
violence and it was heavily serialized
um so I think they came out and they
wanted to distinguish themselves
differently from other broadcast
networks at the time there weren't that
many streamers at the time now there are
of course but I think the number one
thing that they do is they're targeting
niches in a global audience so they know
for example that in Brazil um Brazil
loves uh cop shows or something so
they're targeting they want to find a
cop show that maybe has a a female
detective and some other element that
they know is big in Brazil because they
have all these analytics so they develop
that that little niche show they go out
to creatives and say do you have
anything for this audience and they're
targeting it specifically for that
audience and they definitely want a
global audience because because they
want to sell subscriptions to their
service all over the world so those are
a few of the ways that they distinguish
themselves um and there are some they
don't
necessarily use a different act
structure like a one hour drama on
Netflix uses the basic same teaser plus
4X teaser plus 5x that other streamers
and other networks use for drama you
know that I've broken down in my book um
same with half an hour although half an
hour shows now they either call them 30-
minute dramas or dramedies they are more
experimental some of them are only 21
minutes some of them are over 30
minutes and there's really kind of no
rules really with those um the majority
do a cold open plus three a but there is
a lot of experimentation which is
exciting is there anything different you
will find with the characters of a
Netflix TV show that maybe other
streamers don't have other networks
don't have I mean I would say probably
they're more edgy and dark um a lot of
the Netflix material is dark even if
it's entertaining and even if it's
targeted a younger audience you know a
show like Wednesday is darker than
something that's on like the CW channel
you know a lot of their High School
shows Sabrina and the Teenage Witch or
other ones that I don't even know about
um they're more edgy they're more mature
and maybe that's why they're successful
is they're not dumbing it down for kids
they're not thinking oh only kids are
watching this so I'm going to make this
material less complicated or serious or
edgy you know they definitely have that
thing where they're not afraid to go
dark what is one of your favorite
Netflix Pilots so definitely stranger
things it's one of their most popular
shows ever huge audience and they put a
lot of money into it and they really
Market it because they know people love
it all around the
world and it has a really great pilot it
has a really compelling crazy opening
where there's like a monster and so you
know I don't you don't see the Monster I
think but you see its effects and stuff
um so you know you're in this fantasy
monster type of story where kind of
anything goes then you meet these kids
and you feel kind of the
uh 80s spielbergian type of family
Nostalgia
feeling um kind of reminds you of like
Goonies or ET you know so they have that
Nostalgia element that's the style um
they even show in their in the pitch
deck that they used which you can find
online they have stills from a lot of
like 70s and 80s movies like ET and
Close Encounters of Third Kind and so
they were definitely going for that
right off the bat um but they have
parallel stories so they have the kids
who are looking for their friend who
disappeared and then they have 11 the
girl with the powers who's escaped from
the laboratory so those are parallel
stories until the very end when they
meet and that's kind of the Cliffhanger
like what's going to happen now that
they've met you know and will the boys
know that she has some kind of special
powers and I don't know if she maybe she
doesn't even show her special powers in
the pilot I don't quite remember but you
know that something is amazing with her
she escaped from this secret
Institute um so it has a really good
ending um you also bring in adult
characters wown a ryer um and the
sheriff so you have a good uh cast of
characters different ages different
Generations different tones to their
dialogue um and it's a lot of fun yeah
that's what I was wondering is forgive
me I don't know that much about the show
but that uh because there's
multi-generations and it has this
Nostalgia element to it is that why it's
had such a broad appeal I think it I
think it was a big reason it broke out
to begin with and the same with Cobra
Kai which is also a Netflix show um you
know people of my age remember seeing
the Karate Kid when we were kids in the
80s you know um and then kids today will
follow the younger kids in the show and
they like all the action and kicking and
fights and everything like that um so
yeah I think Nostalgia is a huge thing
you definitely see that a lot with shows
on the air on all different networks um
you're also seeing now movies that are
about pop culture trends like Barbie and
like um there's a movie about the Beanie
Babies you know and so people are like
oh I remember when I played with Barbie
or GI Joe I remember when I had a beanie
baby so that can be a huge thing even if
you don't have um ownership of an
IP kind of the general uh Niche or uh
millu that you are recalling it could
still have an nostalgic element you know
let's say you uh are writing something
about um an 80s rock band and it's not
specifically about you know Foreigner or
de leopard or Guns and Roses but you
kind of uh you fictionalize we know
that's kind of the world that it is
right well that's Nostalgia people
remember hearing those songs on the
radio so that could be a good little uh
window into the world that you could
bring in and Nostalgia could help find
an audience for that yeah and I don't
know if this is true for other
Generations but it seems like younger
people now they like music from a few
Generations ago because the people
there's the debate when was the best
film and music well it was you know
whatever and it's not current and so
some of that is like you know I don't
know if that's true for other
Generations that they liked maybe 20
years prior content but yeah I think you
know I think about that a lot I'm
actually writing a pilot um I have a
pilot that's set in the hair metal era
uh in 1991 in LA and so I think about
Nostalgia a lot and I think about older
trends when I was a kid we romanticized
the 60s
right I remember my older brother even
saying I wish I wish I was born 10 years
earlier so I could have been like a
teenager in the 60s I could have seen
the doors and Le Zeppelin and The Who
and all this stuff and that was the
music he listened to um he didn't listen
to that much modern music even though
there was great stuff happening at that
time but so we romanticized the 60s My
Generation now I think they're Roman
they definitely romanticized the 80s but
now they're getting to the '90s
and it's an era that
they were they were maybe really little
kids or they weren't even born yet and
so they're having their own ideas about
it and they're seeing kind of uh
elevated you know um examples of it in
film and TV you know that maybe weren't
quite accurate to the time but they're
being made into kind of caricatures and
stuff and the music and the movies
they're discovering for the first time
you know you have a like call it needle
drops now so it shows like Euphoria and
stranger things they're actually writing
about what songs they have in each
episode and some of them break out you
know what are the keys to making
audiences binge watch a Netflix series
well Netflix uh from the get-go was
heavily serialized so they are not
afraid to do a lot of plotting they're
not afraid
to have Cliffhangers um but they're not
too reliant on big Cliffhangers because
they know you're just going to go to the
next episode so it's not like you're
going to be waiting for a week you know
um but they one thing they do is they
don't bother to recap the previous
episode because you're binging and they
know you just watched it um I have seen
a few shows lately on other other
streaming services like Max and Hulu and
stuff and they do um it not just the
previously on but they'll kind of back
up the story in the next episode they'll
start with like a minute or so showing
the end of the previous episode and I'm
like why are you doing that because
we're binging it you know this is a
streaming service so that's one thing
they don't worry about um but I think
they use uh they go for high Concepts
you know they get they go for um ideas
that are pretty crazy and edgy and they
uh like I said they target areas of the
world and markets you know very Niche
oriented targeting they use their
analysis to know what audiences are
interested in so maybe that's the the
thing is they know if they're giving an
audience something that they know they
want in Sri Lanka or whatever they know
they're going to binge it you know I
don't know does that touch on that yeah
but we had neelon ratings and so it's
interesting how somehow this seems like
they they really have the viewer dialed
in more so than yeah they have a lot
more analytics than they did back in the
neelen days and also they're thinking
about the whole world you know before it
was North America it was um you know
friends is going to attract 18 million
people on a Thursday night and the main
demo is 18 to 35 you know for example um
and maybe more women watch it than men
maybe it's like 60 40% or something like
that but now they know like in Indonesia
these are the genres that they watch in
this region and this is however many
minutes they watch before they tune out
and go go somewhere else now they know
what audiences are watching in other
countries down to the region and they
know the gender and the ethnicity and
the age and where they live and they
have all these analytics for what topics
and what genres they watch and they know
how long of the episode they watch
before they stop and tune out they know
if they come back to it to finish the
episode or they know if they never come
back to it and then what do they go to
next so maybe they're just uh maybe
they're just sampling that comedy but
they bailed out on that comedy two
minutes in decided they didn't like it
and they went to extraction the movie
with Chris Hemsworth so now they're like
oh okay they're more interested in
action movies and they watched all of
extraction and then they watched
Wednesday so they just they have so much
data that it's just uh a lot more
targeted these days are there any don'ts
when it comes to writing a series for
Netflix uh I would say just try to not
make it feel like a broadcast series
um probably avoid procedurals I would
say procedurals are you know the case of
the week type of shows they're mostly on
broadcast networks there are a few on
streamers like Poker Face uh I guess is
a pretty big hit and that's kind of a um
Columbo type of mystery thing where
there's a different story every week a
different case every week um but Netflix
isn't really doing those so you probably
want to avoid
procedurals and it probably does need to
be more edgy or dark or high concept
than um your genre audience normally
would be on a broadcast network so a cop
show on ABC is probably too broad and
too safe for Netflix they want something
more edgy they want more of a cultural
element maybe a setting that we haven't
seen before so really drill down on
something specific you know be specific
okay so maybe then like an
informant and he's not normally part of
the force but they're going to pay him
to infiltrate this world because they
know that person knew that world or
something and so yeah maybe yeah maybe
like Naros uh was a big hit for them um
there had probably compare like narcos
versus Miami Vice you know true I'm sure
Naros is a lot more intense and there's
going to be more violence and sex and
it's just going to kind of be more
mature it's going to have a bigger
budget it's going to look more cinematic
um than you know a cop show on
ABC